let's go um here we go down to florida
where a man named corey pujols
has just been given some very good news
despite punching an elderly man in the
face and killing him
corey will not be going to prison
he's getting house arrest and probation
house arrest and probation for pujols
for his victim the morgue
so let's back up give some context here
nbc reports it says a florida dunkin
donuts employee was sentenced to two
years on house arrest after he pleaded
guilty to fatally punching a customer
who used a racial slur corey pujols uh
27 was initially
uh charged with aggravated manslaughter
after he punched a 77 year old man in
the jaw following an altercation in may
pleaded not guilty but agreed to change
his plea for the lesser charge of felony
battery the incident began when the
customer identified the associated press
as vanell cook
became upset over the lack of service he
was receiving he was apparently in the
drive-through line and uh the service
was pretty slow as frankly it tends to
be at dunkin donuts and uh you know they
should take some customer service
classes from from chick-fil-a like you
chick-fil-a you could get a chick-fil-a
line
this is not really the point at all but
i'll just say chick-fil-a you get in the
line and there's 30 cars in front of you
and you get in that line and
then you can look over
the parking lot and there's dunkin
donuts and there's three cars in line
and the person who's three cars back
will be in that line longer than you are
30 cars back in the chick-fil-a
so wasn't getting any service to the
dunkin donuts he was upset about that he
went inside um and then nbc continues
police said cook and pujols start
started arguing and that cook called the
dunkin donuts employee was black a
racial slur a criminal report affidavit
states that the customer called him the
n-word and then he told
cook not to repeat it and he did repeat
it
and then corey
jumped over the counter and punched him
in the jaw cook was knocked unconscious
and fell hitting his head on the floor
and had a skull fracture and contusions
on the brain and then he died three days
later
now
so this is an interesting case for me
because the victim vanille cook
is or was rather by all indications of
total scumbag and we do have to
acknowledge that
not only was he berating a minimum wage
customer service worker and calling him
racial slurs because he was upset about
the service being too slow but he was
also
uh according to the reports i've read a
sex offender and a pedophile
it's probably telling that apparently
nobody from cook's family 77 years old
nobody from his family showed up to the
sentencing nobody showed up and in the
family and and you know
protested the fact that
such a light sentence
now i'm personally not at all sad that a
pedophile is dead
what's more even leaving aside the
pedophile bit
if you start screaming in another man's
face
and insulting him
and i don't care what words you use you
start screaming in another guy's face
and insulting him
you deserve to get punched that's my
feeling you deserve it
if you're in a physical state where a
punch to the head might kill you
then watch your mouth is probably the
best way to go
so i i don't see someone as a victim you
start getting in someone's face and
screaming at them and they give you a
chance to stop and you don't
and they even warn you they're gonna
punch you in the face and you keep going
and then you get punched you're the
victim you know i don't really see it
that way you really brought that upon
yourself
i actually and i also don't think that
hitting someone is automatically worse
than insulting them
now i think we have this is sort of this
effeminate
view that people have this really
feminine view that people have that the
worst possible thing you could ever do
is is physical violence is always the
worst thing no i don't think that's
worse than going up to in a guy's face
and
you know verbally spitting spitting in
his face basically or actually spitting
in his face so
that's the way i feel that's my personal
view
and yet my personal views on these
subjects aren't reflected by the law
not necessarily nor should they be
perhaps at least i'm until i'm
theocratic fascist dictator
like i personally think that if you get
in a guy's face and start insulting him
and you get punched that's on you you
had that coming
but that's not what the law says and
probably i'll admit that the law can't
really that's not a precedent you can
actually settle you probably want to set
so um
then you then you think that really what
happened here is a guy was killed for
saying a bad word
do we want to set a precedent that
allows that
i mean
corey the dunkin donuts employee he
didn't know that cook was a pedophile as
far as i know so that didn't that didn't
factor into this
um
he also didn't hit him for screaming and
screaming at him and berating him
generally he hit him specifically for
saying the n-word
and now he gets house arrest
so is the precedent
that people who say this one magical
word
can be killed
the judge in explaining the sentencing
specifically mentioned this he mentioned
a few things he mentioned how well he
didn't mean you know this was not an
intentional homicide he wasn't trying to
kill him he punched him one time
um and that's true you know that does
factor into that it's not premeditated
murder so that's gonna factor into
sentencing but he also mentions
the the severity of the horrible word
that was used like that's because of
that specific word
that's one of the reasons why he's not
going to go to prison
is that the precedent now that if
someone says this word to you
and you're a skirt certain skin color
and they have a certain skin color then
you can kill them
that's certainly the feeling of people
on social media who are celebrating this
to them
they even living aside pedophile leaving
all that aside
cook deserved to die
not because he was a pedophile or
anything else but because he said that
word
you know and the courts seem to have
vindicated this position
which which to me seems rather troubling
and you'll worry about the precedent
there
also i think we could say this
completely destroys the idea of any
anti-black systemic racism in the court
system
this was a black guy who killed a white
guy for saying a word
and isn't even getting
no prison time for it
if our court systems are systemically
racist in an anti-black way then you
would think it wouldn't work out that
way
so interesting case there though well i
hope you enjoyed that clip from the matt
wall show if you did go ahead and hit
that subscribe button right down there
so you can stay up to date on all of our
future content